قواتنا روسيه ونظيرتها البلهروسيه في اطار
تدريب مكثف يهدف الى رفع مستوى التنسيق
والقدرات القتاليه للجيشين
مناورات تبدو اعتياديه كالتي تقوم بها
سائر الجيوش لكن كيف تراها بعين الريبه في
ظل زياره الرئيس الروسي لمسك مصحوبا
بوزيري الدفاع والخارجيه ما يزيد من اهميه
هذه التدريبات المشتركه قياده القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه تعي ان روسيا تجهز 200
جندي جدد لهجوم كبير قد ينطلقوا من الشرق
او الجنوب او حتى من بلروسيا في الربع
الاول او الثاني من العام المقبل
روسيا من جانبها تنفي ما جاء على لسان
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين واصفه تلميحتكيف
الى ان موسكو تهدف الى الضغط على مينسك
للمشاركه في ما تسميها عمليه عسكريه خاصه
هي فبركه غبيه بلا اساس
تتطلب الاوقات الصعبه منا ان تكون لدينا
اراده سياسيه وان يركز على الحصول على
نتائج في جميع مواضيع الاجهزه الثنائيه
وكانت القضايا الرئيسيه في الاونه الاخيره
هي قضايا الدفاع والامن
روسي
اكد في عده مناسبات ان بلاده لن تدخل
الحرب في اوكرانيا رغم ان اراضي بيلاروسيا
كانت منصه لانطلاق الهجمات الروسيه على
كيف في بدايه الحرب
جهات دبلوماسيه غربيه افادت بان دخول
بيلاروسيا الحرب بشكل مباشر سيلاقي رفضا
داخليا ويعقد الاوضاع للنظام الحكم في
منزلي خاصه مع تصاعد الاصوات المعارضه
لسلطه لوكشن كل المطلقه في الداخلي
والخارج
انس نماسي العربيه